cette tragédie syrienne sera devant
l'histoire
une honte pour la communauté
internationale si nous n'y mettons pas
fin rapidement
pour l'instant on ne bouge pas léger
sait pas on ne bougera pas et j'ai
occulté mais je nageais bourdin enfin
jouer upa mois à la tête des du culte
musulman on est d'accord montana il
suffit de chaleur a d'ailleurs dit moi
les convois humanitaires sont attaqués
des armes chimiques sont utilisés
eh bien je dès qu'un seul mot à dire ça
suffit pour que c'est surtout françois
hollande ça suffit parce que
l'impuissance de la france dans le
conflit syrien son impuissance sur la
scène européenne face au drame des
réfugiés
ces sacs dont j'ai envie de dire ça
suffit
nicolas sarkozy en visite à calais le
candidat à la primaire de la droite veut
mettre la crise des migrants au centre
de sa campagne
hazard mise en scène en ouvrons une
remorque transportant de la mousse le
candidat entouré de plusieurs élus dont
le président de la région servier
bertrand tombe nez à nez avec douze
migrants des avions et des syriens
ar calais c'est une honte c'est une
honte pour la france
à ces ballons sur les êtres humains vous
avez raison mais c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont malheureux
je regrette effectivement que calais
devienne un objet politique un objet de
campagne électorale parce qu'on sait
tous que dans les campagnes électorales
en règle générale les mots dépassent
souvent la pensée et les mots ce n'est
pas souvent la réalité ce qu'on peut
faire
après cette campagne présidentielle ce
s'ouvre sous de mauvais auspices parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de la question
sécuritaire puisque du social évidemment
évidemment la liste des candidats à la
primaire de la droite et du centre est
désormais officielle
elle vient d'être rendue publique à
l'instant par la haute autorité chargée
d'étudier la validité des candidatures
par pas de suspense vous concernant rien
c'est sûr mais nous et à pratiquer il ya
une ou deux personnes qui essayent de
l'entretenir
qui sont les mêmes qui pendant six mois
on dit elle n'y arrivera pas là mais mon
chéri l'empêcher bon psychologiquement
ils apprennent avec le faire cette voie
elle angoissée ils seront donc sept en
tout une femme et six hommes vous les
découvrez ici par ordre alphabétique
hervé mariton a été recalé et n'a pas
rassemblé les 250 élus dont vingt
parlementaires aussi bien 13 parrainage
qui pose problème
alors si j'en avais été posée mais vous
avez déposé 2520 pour vous dire j'en ai
20 de marge mais si effectivement sur
les 2500 20 20 à 90 qui soit n'ont pas
payé soit n'ont pas signé soit on soit
en doublon vous être juste chargée sur
le plan humain une pensée pour hervé
parce que les preuves des difficiles à
supporter à vivre voilà donc je ne
m'arrête je n'arrive pas à me réjouir
complètement de cette nouvelle même si
évidemment politiquement ça ouvre un
champ qui est un peu nouveau pour moi